[Music]
right we've been dating for over a year
now and I think it's about time people
met my beautiful girlfriend what about
us taking an adventure ease like Queens
Singapore Holland's wedding don't you
want to be my family every time I bring
them up the cages maybe his parents are
poor and he has to send them money
take a bag then get you checked into
Presta can't afford this so your family
is rich we're comfortable that is
exactly what a super rich person would
say 1.2 minutes is Nikki young yeah
they're just the biggest developers and
all a Singaporean bachelors if you
aren't just rich they're crazy with you
really should have told me that you know
like the principal um of Asia
that's ridiculous much more of a hurry
pump this is Rachel chick she just
thinks you're some like unrefined banana
there's a few fingers no on the outside
or white on the inside
it was okay that I chose to raise a
family for me it was a privilege but for
you you may think it's old-fashioned
don't you want it to be happy I know
you're not what Nick needs she's like
trying to play games chicken with me
thinking I'm gonna swerve like a chicken
but you can't were you gonna roll up and
be like Bock Bock bench
okay maybe even like not as aggressive
I met a girl I fell in love and I wanna
marry her your Nicholas young you're
untouchable but Rachel's not if you
prepped Rachel to face the walls I
really admire you
it takes guts coming all the way over
here phasing expanding I know this much
you will never be enough
no it's about time someone stood up to
answer Eleanor
well you not me Oh God Chicago is over
here
[Music]
ever since I can remember my family has
been my whole life
Rachel Rachel if Nick chose me he would
lose his family and if he chose his
family he might spend the rest of his
life for Zen ting you you dad you got an
ass you got nasty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]